Science...
...is incredible.
We got talking robots...
Self-Driving Cars...
Virtual Reality is becoming real...
And Now...
The next big step for humanity and science...
The amazing team of Microsoft Engineer
Have developed a program that will caption any-
an- ANY image!
PERFECT.
Let's show how it works...
Use this photo.
*reading off text on-screen*
*Pewds is amazed*
How the f*** did it know that?!
*Pewds is still amazed*
How is that possible?
What is this?
I don't even know what this is...
A grilled sandw-
*LE GASP*
*Mind has been blown*
Have you seen "Terminator"?
This is Step One.
How could we have been so blind?
HOW COULD HAVE WE BEEN SO BLIND?!
We shouldn't have abused our powers.
The robots are here and they are here to f*** with us!
Arnold Schwarzenegger was RIGHT!
*reading a quote from the God himself*
How could we have been so blind?
This is the end of humanity.
This. Is the end.
Let's try another picture.
*reading the text of a stupid and clueless robot on-screen*
Maybe. There is hope for humanity after all.
What about this image?
*reads the atrocious words of a robot who has never seen the truth*
Now I don't know, how giraffes next to a window would look like.
But I am fairly certain...
THIS. IS NOT IT!!
Do you think I don't see through your lies?
THIS! IS A GIRAFFE LOOKING THROUGH A WINDOW!
NOW THIS! IS A GIRAFFE!!
LOOKING THROUGH A WINDOW!
THIS IS A S**TTY MEME!!
What about DJ Khaled?
Can it recognize DJ Khaled?
"I am 98% sure that's DJ Khal-"
*magic*
I knew it.
*now back to the bot being a dumb dumb*
Now why the F*** WOULD YOU USE A SURFBOARD IN A SKATE PARK?!
What about this meme of JackSepticEye?
It's spot-on again.
(I am not writing this in the caption)
*Again with the giraffes?*
WHAT IS THIS OBSESSION WITH GIRAFFES?!
Anotha one.
*Is that a cow???*
Yeah. Yeah, that's-
THAT'S A GOAT, YOU F***ING IDIOT!!!
What about ME?
What about me?
*it's got one part right*
*the teddy bear part, of course. What did you think I meant?*
how f***ing dare you
I'm gonna tell tumblr about this.
I will find the Giraffes... ( Falcon Lovers )
...and I will put them to justice.
Including whoever is responsible for this CaptionBot.
ow.
I'm watching you...
(And so are we, Pewds. So are we.)
*LE 2ND GASP*
Alright Bros! Thank you so much for watching another video! If you enjoyed, thank you for leaving a like! I really appreciate it!
Post on my FaceBook page some of the results you got from Capt-
*burps* -ionBot.
And as always, Thank You Bros so much for watching!
Stay Awesome Bros!!
https://www.youtube.com/user/JlipperRoblox